college costs a fortune most Americans
can't afford tuition fortunately some
colleges now put their professors
lectures online so everyone can learn
here's a sample how we derive energy
from triglyceride this Berkeley video
makes chemistry interesting because
carbon and hydrogen are nonpolar those
are insoluble for five years anyone
could access 20,000 videos on Berkeley's
website but then President Obama's
Justice Department sent Berkeley this
threatening letter
Berkeley's in violation of title 2 the
Attorney General may initiate a lawsuit
it's all because of a well intended law
called the Americans with Disabilities
Act both blatant and subtle
discrimination a young al gore pushed
for that law President Bush senior's
signed it both parties applauded who
wouldn't who could object to a law that
says no individual with a disability
shall be denied the benefits of services
but as usual the good intentions had
unintended consequences all lectures are
being deleted so now no one can access
them Berkeley took its videos down
because closed captioning is expensive
it has to be done by a person who
listens and then types out each word
computers can transcribe cheaply but
they're lousy at it when a Harvard video
said on our campus
it was transcribed as hot camp and good
our experience transcriptionists will
perfectly transcribe your recordings
Berkeley didn't want to spend millions
on companies like this so it blocked
everyone from seeing its lectures
everyone's treated equally hearing
people have no advantage over the deaf
nobody gets to see the videos government
equality police doing their work but
fortunately the videos will survive
thanks to the internet and pissed off
entrepreneurs like Jeremy Kaufman we're
gonna keep it available Kaufman
downloaded all the Berkeley videos
before they were taken down and reposted
them to his web site library spelled
funny the Justice Department might say
you're you're making life tougher for
deaf people I don't think any one thing
that it wouldn't be better if stuff who
are subtitled for deaf people but at the
same time it's ridiculous to say this
content can't be available unless it's
subtitled for deaf people Coffman says
he wants to help deaf people but when
closed captioning costs millions is that
a reason that content shouldn't be
available to everyone do you want to put
a gun to someone's face and say caption
those videos it's absurd it is absurd
but what government does is often absurd
thank goodness for the Internet and
people like Coffman someone willing to
spend his own money to keep information
free
you